how come it sounds like JK Rowling has
just spilled her guts to you you know
you know stuff that he doesn't well no
I'm not sure we have we haven't
cross-reference this year actually but I
when I was asked to play the part the
first thing I felt was my responsibility
was to meet JK Rowling and to question
her about the the backstory and the the
life of this incredible character
because he is hugely beloved and I felt
like it was a big responsibility so she
talked through his childhood a lot of
which we all know from the Harry Potter
books up to this point and she went a
little beyond but not hugely I mean and
most of what she told me was about
Albert's not about everyone else so I
you know I know a little bit I'm really
sticking to this don't talk about it
close
don't pretend you stick to the no really
boring person you will not give you an
actual you get cast as young Dumbledore
the one thing you do know is you live
all I have to worry about is growing up
keeping that big growing that's there
yeah yeah but a big reaction from sort
of confused reaction from fans here's
some of the tweets when it got announced
I mean Dumbledore just got 200% Jude Law
is playing a young heart and gay
Dumbledore next vidoe soubise I'm
sweating already this this I think sums
it up quite nicely
Dumbledore more like double 10
[Applause]
[Music]
you